北防そんな人に注意できるほど大した人間じゃないんですけどまぁそんな僕でもさすが
にこれは馬鹿なんじゃないかっていうかまぁ頭ぶっ飛んずんじゃねーかって思うから
ちょっと変な人が3人いたんでそれでちょっと動画にさせていただきますセンサーの
ただただを怒ってるの船怒ってますて怒っていると有利こういう人がいるんだ
あっていう恐怖いやもうすどういう思考回路でそんなことできるんだろうなっていう
その人たちこの動画見たら普通におかしいなと思ってほしいし
多分タイトルで内容だいたい皆さんわかっていると思いますけどもまたうちにですね人
が来ましてこの自粛期間
緊急事態宣言が出てるなんかまあこういう動画だすとそんなの何か晒すから人が来るん
でって言いますけど
鉄球でだ
絵だって言わないときちゃうんですよそういう人達ってこういう動画だ知ったりか
まったりそれから来ちゃうって言われるんですけどたまにやっぱり来ちゃダメって
ちゃんと僕の使い1ときちゃう人って絶対るんで方がただちょっとマジでやばいなって
思ったんですよね動画にさせていただいております
まあこうやってやがれルガーノ牧目線になって動画見ていただくとその人たちも多分
歩きがあっ
犯すんであーおかしいけど少なくとも僕目線になったらやっぱ悪いか取ったら読めない
ことしてるんだなっていうのが見て分かったらうれしいなんか持っていると動画にして
おりますね2020年5月の5日こどもの日まだ日本全国に緊急事態宣言自粛期間の
要請が出ている月にゴールデンウイークだから彼らはわけわかんない人だったんだよ
なぁ
まずストリーがですね
の家族連れの男の子です
えっと午前2ぐらいから家に来られてピンポン音後6回ずっとね押して押してという
行動されててるが名理由でしたね
そのことをもう一人から完全にも大人の社会人みたいな方
この人がちょっと分けわかんなかったんですけどこの方もゆずまで来られてピンポンは
何回かされてなんですけども3階のベランダから結構距離置いてちょっと話してみたん
でちょっとまたそちらをご覧下さい
どうぞ
先導されましたーーー
あって同市のさん
はい
なんでも屋さんなんでも屋さん
ダサいからピンポンを押されています
じゃあちょっと聞こえないです
はい
何回かテープを押されますか
それちょっと聞こえないです
はい
なんでも屋さんで何をされてるんですか
今でも多分ご時世的に自粛期間だと思うんですよ
緊急事態宣言を出てますよね緊急事態宣言が出てるんですよ全国に
そういう期間中に色んな家庭もあるのってどうなんですか
はいっ
任されている
そうなんですよの
5自宅にいるのが今
一般的に不要不急の外出がダメだと思うんで
お家に来るのも迷惑だと思うんですよ
富士山なピンポンたくさんされて嫌なんで
ちょっとやめていただいていいですか
ハイあの男の子は何ですかつみん
そうなんですね
ちょっと宇宙止めていただけると
助かりますよね
はい
なんでも屋さんだっていた
やばいよ以下
大人よめっちゃメンバーされたが断った後はきたす
まずこのおっとこの人何歳なんだろ多分普通に俺と同い年て来ないかちょっと下ぐらい
20代前後半くらいの方だったんですけどもやばくないですか何でも屋さんっていうん
かわけわかんそれはちょっとほんとことが怪しいんですよも全然信じてないんですけど
話を聞くながいろんな家庭に回ってなんでも屋さん
やってるって言うんですけどこの的にはまぁいろんなかテーマばんだ歯かマジなので
ワンちゃんね普通にやばいよやってることその方がまず酒造なのか立ってのわかんない
じゃないですかもしかしたら東京からの出張で来てるからかもしんないしどこから来た
かわかんない人がいろんな人に尋ねているわけですよもしその人は感染者といろんな人
の家待ってるいろんな縁全部に完成しますからねマジで最悪
混ぜてびっくりしたしお話ししてみた感じ無効な2子立知ったんで多分その正当な理由
じゃないとみましたあげくの果てになり人に頼まれたからやってるって何なんかの真似
で人が会社があるんだったらそこまで聞けばよかったなと思って待ってま正直体くらい
ちょっと java へ風ってんだと思ってとりあえずなんでも屋さんと言う訳わかん
ない名目でいろんな人の家庭にこの時期
終わってるみたいですまあ安いですけど絶対明らかに別の何かん訳わかんない事言って
たんだと思うんですけど普通にあるせる
一環でてますマジそしてもうひとりあのとこの子ですねそろそろピンポンパンマンをし
なくったあとうちの味袋ゾロして何でちょっと話してみました
はい
から t 本をしてる
ちょっと迷惑だからさー
見てほしい俺の動画で家こられると困るって言って店を知ってる
見てないこれじゃオレンジなんだここ
だから直接ピンポンされると
俺どう思うと思う
塗ってたんよ
寝てたの
寝てたのにさん突然知らない人からピンポン5回も6回もされると嫌でしょ
だから家には来て欲しくないんだよ
あんっ
灰崎てたあの
わかるからピンポンされたらさっき the おうちの人もいなかったん
どっ
を散らしたなんて言ってたなぁ
何も言ってなかったあるねえ
人の家に確認しちゃダメなんだよ
だからもう来ないでほしいってお父さんとお母さんいる今
味いる
ちょっと呼べたら読んで来てもらっていい
子犬
やっぱり家族に来てる凄くいい
い子供技悪い竿でみなさーん
ct ならそれを止めるのは応援だってほしいよおやように説教したするためにも開か
れるさん
これこいつヒットするよまじでした方がいいてくださいません
今の高さ
年齢関係ないよここはずも式大人いってばまずうんポリー
に変えてこのご時世てくるんだからさタイミングもやっていることも左翼ですからね
ああ
2桁目で小屋
交え
これないって言ったどうしたのか
なんでくれないかな
馬鹿なのか
ガー
泣きたくないよね行きたくないおりゃは男女買ってるんだ
とりあえず
あなたはもしよ君の家に突然知らないときたらどう思う
いやでしょ
それもセラてたら五回も六回5 p もうしてくるんやでしょ
そうだかもう切っちゃダメね分かっていてもいつの間もちょっとあると思うんだ
あそこはバレているのはもう仕方ないよバレてたら行っていいの
ダメでしょピンポーンたくさんしたら迷惑だ
だから今後はやめてくださいでお父さんでも言っといて
怒られたっていう
まずしまいますけど心の危ないから取れずちょっと今外に出るのあぶないよ
さあ入る沿い
気をつけろ
大設けねーよああ
親だね完全様やだってこいってきてないんだよ
本来多分すぐ退かなかったら普通にこの親とか言って俺普通に起こってですけど今人と
接触時代下げたり
事件で親また色づく一緒にをずっとそんな感じです
あのこの後も悪いけどやっぱ家族とかねほぼさの方がこれは止めるべきだったのでは
ないかなと思うし
あがさーんてかさんそれはいつも話を自粛期間がなかったら物のそうなんですけどそう
じゃなくて今外に田ら放射を含め
なんでマスクして寝親も保護さんも子供もま伏せなくて家に来てるとピンポン押して
こちらも
恐怖でしかないからね普通に移され貼ってるんですねやすちょっと保護者の方それ
さーんゴムにダメっていうのはあなたの仕事じゃないんですか保護した家族の皆さん
はじめ社長の家だから動画とかじゃなくて僕がの立場になってもらったらパルドんです
けど知らない人が家にピンポン後ろっかしたらも普通にやばいす寄せる人に警察もん
ですよだがそんな人たちのために僕の時間錯のをもったいないなと思ってるんで契約
人がは呼ばなかったですけどねなんか毎回こういうことあるんですけどもそれも大前提
として今回はその自粛期間です緊急事態宣言が出てて不要不急の外出を控えを打ちに
いってくださいって言われてるなんか家族と一緒に子供を着てそれも親も一緒に家の前
まで来てピンポンを吸ってるもうねぇ
大丈夫かなって思っちゃいますね周りが見えてないのかな
ちょっとびっくりしたという話ですはい
そういう人たちがいるからサーメンかまだ感染が止まらなくてさー緊急対戦ゲーとかで
出費感あるわけじゃんそういうあんたらせて一生この自粛期間とか緊急事態宣言が伸び
て
を1ないっすよこの状況みんな我慢してんのにさぁっていう話です
ちょっと熱くなってしまいましたいやーなんかすごい身をもって体感したねこれを3
安打と思ったはどんな芸人だよがんばって自粛しのそういう人
落ちあげるんだから我慢できずに外でちゃったりわけわかんないけどする人たちがいる
せいでピック感染者が止まらないんだったらもう本当に頑張ってる皆さんにとっては
もうスレないんですけどもこのままずーっと自粛期間
剣術だしてみて何ずっと続くのかも知れませんほんの少数だと思うんですけどほんと今
だけ短期間みんなでガマンすれば止まると信じて一歳
食は先でしかないと思うんで今一度ちょっと自分の行動を2回してみてください
びっくりしました
記載や義務です
筋トレすぎます
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
ああああああ